[موسيقى]
كنت صغير بحاول اتحدى اي شيء يرسم فيه ما
شرط اني امسك الم وارسم عليه يمكن طب شو
صغير على حيط اني حاول ارسم مشهد شفته
قدامي لفتني اكثر شيء الوجوه حسيت تعبير
الوجوه بتعنينه كتير بتعطيني شغف للرسم
اكثر من اني ارسم طبيعه او ارسم الوان
كان عندي نوع من التحدي باي شيء ممكن اني
ارسم باي ماده ممكن اني اعمل فيها لوحه
فيني ارسم على اي خامه
في تفاصيل معينه كنت اسعى اني ارسمها
بالوجه لمعه العين حركه التم النجره العين
وين بتكون اهتم بها التفاصيل هاي اللي
طلعها دقيقه كتير
المرات تستخدم غير الريشه والالوان
العاديه على لوحه استخدم احيانا الصمغ
اجتني اول فرصه بحفل للملصقات المرحوم
ملحم بركات رسلت خلال حوالي خمس دقايق
فكانت هذه الها صدى كبير عند الناس ومن
هون
دخلت الموضوع تاني اني ارسم المقلوب
وبعدين اللوحه مع نهايه العرض
بعدين طورت الفكره اكثر اني اعمل اربع
لوحات لوحات دواره كل ما عم تدور تتشكل
لوحه جديده
انت بتحدد الخط اذا بدك تمشي عليه يلي بدك
توصل فيه رسالتك على هدفك ما تكون تقليدي
خليك يكون عندك اسلوب خاص فيه الابداع
ماله حدود
[موسيقى]